We're talking today
with Jianming Zhou,
and, Ryder Pearce
the co-founders
of a very interesting
organization
called SherpaShare.
It works in the ride
service business,
and it provides
services both to drivers
and to other people companies
interested in this business.
So we're very interested
in learning more about
what you do, why you
founded your organization,
and where it's going.
So welcome, thank you
for joining us today.
Thank you.
Thanks for having us.
So tell me what is SherpaShare?
What is it that you do?
Yeah so SherpaShare is
financial management,
and a communication platform
for on-demand workers.
And we basically
offer them to access--
basically offer them an
independent and neutral
platform to access
information, utility,
and work opportunities
to maximize their work.
And tell me a
little bit about why
you formed this organization.
What led you to do it?
The fundamental reason
is we see there's
a fundamental conflict
between on-demand services
and the workers And the
workers are typically
working for multiple
services, and they
have growing challenges
to manage their work,
and understand that there
are all other work options.
And they don't have
loyalty to any services.
At the same time a company
competing for the same supply
pool, and they have very
high acquisition cost.
And so we think
a sort of putting
in a buffer layer in between
can benefit both sides.
So that's why we position
us to sell that need.
And so who do you define as your
customers for your services?
So typically it's been
ride share drivers
is who we've started with.
And those typically,
Uber, Lyft, formerly
Sidecar, and delivery
companies as well
although we'd like to expand
to other independent drivers.
And do the companies
themselves come to you
with ideas for your
services or ask you
for either information that's
helpful to them as well?
Some, yeah.
Especially for smaller players.
So basically, if you're
looking for a channel
to acquire supplies--
but actually for the
workers, they also
are looking for a
third party channel
to exchange information
as well, yeah.
You know what I find fascinating
is you characterize SherpaShare
an intermediary, not as a
representative or an advocate
for one party or the other.
Tell me more about
how that works
and why you're positioning
Sherpa share in this kind
of middle category?
What do each of the
different stakeholders
get from your Services
Yeah so, as I said, like
most workers actually
working for multiple
services, so because they
are working for
multiple services,
they need tools to
manage your earnings
from different sources,
check their personal expenses
understand that
their tax liability,
and navigate increasingly
more working options.
And no single on-demand
services can't actually
provide the necessary
tools to help them.
And other side is on-demand
services are very powerful,
and workers are actually
on the weak side.
And they don't-- they are
forced into a Silo Situation.
So that's why we
think like SherpaShare
as a third party can
provide value on both sides,
make the transaction more
smooth and efficient.
Yeah, for example,
so that the workers
don't have loyalty,
as J.Z. Said,
and so workers who
need a place where they
can manage their
multiple work options
and also communicate with each
other and exchange information.
And the problem the
companies are having is,
they basically don't
have a good way
to demand loyalty,
or command loyalty.
And that's one of
things we see they're
struggling with quite a bit.
How do they actually
convince a driver,
who has multiple options,
to work for them.
And that's in many ways to
challenge of the on demand
economy where you don't have
a direct employer and employee
relationship in place, so
that the interaction is
a little bit more fluid.
So I think that's a
very interesting point.
So your services
come via an app.
Take me through the app.
If I'm a driver, what do I do?
How do I get access to it?
What will I learn
by using your app?
Yeah, so, also it's actually--
have a mobile app.
We also have a website.
So we provide a tool to
help you to consolidate all
your earnings into one place.
We also use a mobile app
to track your expense
automatically.
Now since [INAUDIBLE]
focus on the drivers,
so the biggest expense for
them actually is mileage.
So we track the mileage
for them automatically.
We also have so-called heat
map, which is across map,
and show where the hot spot
for the drivers in real time.
So they can, based
on the heat map
decide when and where to
work for each service.
And we also have a
so-called chat feature,
so kind of chat room,
so drivers can get help,
get support from other drivers.
Yeah that's basically
what we have now.
Today we are
launching a new app.
As of last week.
We launched a brand new app that
basically took the chat feature
and gave it its own home.
So when we launched the
chat in our existing
app we found that, drivers--
it was a strong need for drivers
to communicate with each other,
to ask questions, to
give status updates.
What's it like down time
right now, for example.
When does the game get out?
And so last week, we
launched a new app
dedicated to basically
allowing drivers
to exchange information.
Call it SherpaShare Plus.
Real time exchange [INAUDIBLE].
For example, when I
came in this morning,
I posted something
saying, hey, we're
going to be in Boston
talking about driver issues,
anything you want to talk about?
And we had several
drivers right away
respond, a couple the
points where repeat--
Uber should add
tips for drivers,
so that was one that drivers
And tips.
And temps it was the one.
And a few others, basically
saying that drivers
want to communicate more.
So if companies can
do more or if we
can do more to help
drivers communicate,
it's a strong lead.
That's very interesting
that drivers are--
they operate
independently, separately,
they're all in their
own vehicle, And so on.
But they're looking for
some sense of community,
and communications.
That's and that's a service
that you can provide.
That's very interesting.
Yeah, there's like two
fundamental needs drivers need.
The number one is
always financial need.
The second need, we
actually call social need.
So basically, they
need a channel
to talk about their career.
And so basically they talk
to passengers every day.
But they need to talk
to other drivers,
talk about their company, talk
about their so-called career,
in some way.
So we want to
become that channel.
Well that's a
fascinating opportunity
for people to do
it in a modern way.
Do you know if this creates
any social networking where
people drivers
actually physically get
together, and form communities
or is it all online?
Both, actually.
Yeah, there is some
offline we see more.
I mean, online is the
big one, because everyone
has different schedules
and so it's hard to align.
But traditional
employment of course,
had lunch, break, the break
room, the water cooler which
doesn't exist for the drivers.
We would like to replicate
the online chat as the water
cooler area.
We do see in some cities where
there are a lot of drivers,
the drivers will coordinate.
Hey, I'm taking a break
at this coffee shop
now and trying to get
a few people together.
So it's kind [INAUDIBLE]
of our platform.
Drivers can organize
whatever they want,
whether that's discussions
or offline meet-ups.
Another name for
on-demand industry
is some people call O2O,
which is online to offline,
or offline to online.
Actually, our community
is very interesting we
develop a community
from offline to online.
But eventually we
also want to bring
online to offline in some way.
Well there's all
kinds of opportunities
for that kind of interaction.
Well let's talk more
specifically about the drivers
and how they are
doing, financially.
You're providing
both information
for helping them build
a social network,
but also to assess their
own financial situation.
What are you hearing
from drivers?
What can you say about how
they are doing financially now,
and over time?
Yeah the biggest thing we
found at a fundamental level
was a lot of these drivers are
first time independent workers.
And so understanding
expenses, mileage tracking,
wasn't really there so I
didn't have a basis for that.
And so what that
meant was, whatever
Uber and Lyft and other
companies marketed to them.
They say $35 an hour.
Drivers didn't have
a good sense of what
their actual net earnings was.
And that's why we started,
that's how we started basically
showing them, here's what
you're actually making.
Another issue we saw was
that basically drivers didn't
know how to
optimize, their work,
and so there's a couple things
that we've helped them with.
And so we put out
reports every once
in a while that show
trends in different cities.
And we do see that
earnings per trip, I mean,
they do fluctuate.
In some cities they go
up, some they go down.
Of course, people's schedules
are vastly different.
So it's always been
very difficult to point
to a trend in either direction.
But what I will say
is that we noticed
that the vast majority
of these workers
are doing this for
supplemental income.
And so this might be 10 hours
a week or 20 hours a week.
And that's in the range of--
they might make a couple
hundred dollars more,
in addition to full time work
What do you hear from
the drivers themselves?
What would they like
SherpaShare to do?
They will definitely like--
always want to make more money.
Yeah, and so whatever we
do can increase the income,
they will love it.
So we basically organize all
our service in in three buckets.
The first one is help them
to sort of like manage--
count their money, right?
Manage their money.
Second is basically how to help
them to optimize their income.
The third bucket
is basically how
to help them make more money.
So if you look at our
service, basically, we
provide us some
personal utility tools
to help them to
count their money.
There will be a community.
So with some cross
[INAUDIBLE] information, so
they can make better
decisions every day.
Hopefully they can optimize
their work and maximize income.
The third thing we
eventually will do
is connect them with a
new working opportunity,
so they can make more money.
Yeah.
And so that's what the
drivers get from you.
What's your revenue model?
How do you survive,
and you have investors
know as a startup
organization, but you
are a for profit business?
So what's the model
for generating revenue?
Yeah, so we are an
intermediate layer
between the on-demand
services and workers.
And so we're also a
layer between workers
and, other work
related services,
and worker and consumer, right.
So we eventually will make
money from every relationship.
So we will start with some
premise of this on the worker
side, then try to make some
money on the company side,
through some marketing and
[INAUDIBLE] kind of things.
So marketing opportunities
for companies,
and pay for services,
from drivers,
for more premium kind of
information and material.
Exactly.
So an example of that would be
what's most valuable to drivers
now is tracking
mileage, because that's
a direct number they can look
at and use for a tax direction,
and so that's something where
a lot of other utility services
charge for, and drivers
are willing to pay for.
So that's one example
on the worker side
they'll pay for that utility.
And the company
side, they'll see
that there's a
network of drivers
who have a certain level of
experience in this space.
And of course, those
are potential drivers
that they want to target.
So that's, of course, they're
interested in both acquiring
those drivers and
then once they've
acquired them, convincing
them to work on a certain day.
Yeah, so in some respects, you
can be a recruiting agency,
or help them to identify the
pool of potential drivers
for them.
So that's a really
important service
because that must
be very difficult,
what do you find is-- how
stable are these drivers?
How long do they stay?
Do they turn over a lot?
What's your experience
telling you?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
There's a natural turn
for this industry.
Yeah, and sometimes we use
a metaphor, travel industry,
so more like the
travel industry.
Like every family, they want
travel two to three times
a year, something like that.
Before this industry
extreme, more like people
work on and off kind of thing.
So for us it's more like
a we provide a platform
with data and information
that, whenever
they decide to do
something in this industry,
they will go to SherpaShare.
And hopefully, with
the entire industry
become more mature,
average higher,
I think the people will
find that this is more
a legit viable work option
for them to make a living.
So an example of
that would be someone
who was on boards with
Uber, for example,
might only really want
that income for a month,
or a week even, to have
some supplemental income,
and then leave for six months.
And that's a pattern we
see, where people really
want someone come for
a fixed period of time,
and then they might leave.
And the question that we're
always wondering is at--
and we believe at
some point they'll
come back, because
they'll want extra income.
It's a question of when is
the next phase of their life
where they'll need
supplemental income?
So it could be students is a
good example, where students
will-- on our way
over here we had
an Uber driver who was
also a full time student,
and a full time driver.
And he fits in his driving
when he's a student,
but after he's done,
after he graduates,
he'll probably find
a full time job
and scale back on the driving.
So you fit it into sort of the
life courses, people's life
changes, and responsibilities
change, and time allocations.
Right.
And then the other end
is when people are older,
and they have more
free time, they'll
also become drivers as well.
There are a lot of
controversies in this industry,
as you know, questions
about whether drivers
should be independent
contractors or employees.
Concerns on some chat rooms
and various online linking
mechanisms that Uber doesn't
really care about the drivers.
What are you hearing?
Where are you positioned?
Do you hear these
kinds of things?
Do you see them as credible?
What's your view of
some of the critiques
of this industry at the moment?
I think some concerns
are true in some degree,
and we are kind of
happy that we see
some other groups
supporting workers as well,
and we are honored to be a very
important channel for drivers
to voice out their concerns.
We actually want to take a
neutral, independent position.
I think that the entire
on-demand industry
needs protection, right?
So they would definitely
need to protect workers,
but we'll also need to
protect the service side.
So I think the better
way is, collect data,
build some channels,
allow them to communicate,
I think eventually they will
find a balance somewhere, yeah.
Well I think this role
of providing information
as a basis for fostering more
communications between all
of the parties who have
a stake in this industry
as an important service
that you're providing.
So help me envision
where you will
be five years from now
what will SherpaShare look
like if you are successful?
We want to become the
number one support
platform for on-demand
workers around the globe.
And so currently we are only
focused on the driver vertical
only US bucket, but we want
to expand to other verticals
and other regions as well.
So that's we will hope in
the next five years, yes.
So basically all those workers
will be exchanging information
on our platform, and
so whatever service
they want to work for
whatever opinion they have,
they're use SherpaShare
as like they're
in the exchange for
that information.
So your point earlier
about giving them a voice
is something we really
want to emphasize.
So that we don't necessarily
care what the voice is,
but we give you the channel
to basically express yourself.
The ultimate vision, I'm
thinking, is it's more like a--
drivers say, I have
eight hours for work.
And SherpaShare put up a
working portfolio for him,
so he can hit his financial
goal on a daily basis.
So they can look at where their
optimal opportunities are,
what times of day,
what days of the week,
and how to balance that
with all of their other
responsibilities, and
be efficient in making
those choices.
Well it's very interesting.
It's a very creative
organization.
We appreciate your sharing
your insights with us
for this course.
We wish you all
the best, and thank
you very much for
taking the time
to come across the country.
You don't have an Uber
service in the area.
So I guess you had to
go by commercial airline
until you land, and
then you could--
We didn't take Uber helicopter.
You didn't take Uber helicopter.
Well maybe some day that will
be part of all of our future.
So, thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thanks.